merci eric bonjour à tous oui je crois
qu'on peut l'applaudir que tout le
travail qui me faire pour élaborer le
projet les républicains pour les années
qui viennent merci eric donc nous avons
demandé comme tu l'as dit à trois
éleveurs devenir introduire nos débats
de ce matin vous faites du lait et du
comté vous nous expliquerez tout à
l'heure vous faites du lait et aussi de
la production ovine donc vous c'est le
doubien sur le compte et vous c'est
l'auvergne et puis vous faites du port
en bretagne donc avec une petite touche
particulière je suis moi député d'ille
et vilaine un département où l'élevage
est très important et donc on est
directement concernée par la crise où la
mutation vous traversez aujourd'hui
alors pour introduire les débats et
avant de vous entendre
j'ai repris parce que je trouve que
c'est très intéressant c'est assez
révélateur de l'impuissance publique
j'ai repris le discours du premier
ministre du 3 septembre dernier qui
faisait suite à aux événements qu'on a
connu cet été je trouve que c'est très
instructif
sachez qu'aujourd'hui le premier
ministre ne nous répond plus à aucune
question que nous posons à l'assemblée
nationale sur les questions
d'agriculture il fait répondre monsieur
le foll à croire qu'il n'a vraiment
aucune idée de la question et qu'il est
probablement à mon avis dans le déni je
le cite les agriculteurs n'ont pas
besoin d aide
ils veulent des prix la priorité c'est
d'enrayer la baisse des prix stéphane le
foll maintiendra la pression pour que
les engagements annoncés par les
industriels et les distributeurs soient
tenus en 2015 les prises en charge les
intérêts d'emprunt s'élèveront à 100
millions d'euros sur le budget de l'état
c'est parce qu'il sera pris pour vous
les prises en charge des cotisations
sociales 50 millions un report total des
annuités de 2015 seront proposées une
dotation supplémentaire viendra abonder
le fonds d'allègement des charges fac en
2015 et en 2016 les charges des
agriculteurs doivent également être
réduites dès 2015 un alignement de la
cotisation minimum maladie sur le régime
des indépendants permettra une baisse de
50 millions des cotisations sociales
un chantier sera ouvert sur la fiscalité
agricole on a demain une proposition de
loi qui nous arrive du sénat dans
laquelle on va faire des propositions
sur la fiscalité
on verra comment réagissent nos
collègues députés socialistes
un travail en profondeur sera menée pour
moderniser les outils de production
améliorer la performance d exploitation
pour agir aussi sur la segmentation les
produits miser sur les énergies
renouvelables le gouvernement portera à
350 millions par an pendant trois ans
les moyens publics de soutien à
l'investissement avec la pluie de
l'union européenne et des régions et ça
c'était le 3 septembre
je réunirai d'ailleurs dans les
prochaines semaines les présidents de
région je crois pas que ça a été fait
j'attends beaucoup d'un rapport qui me
sera remis en septembre sur l'innovation
en agriculture et qui doit déboucher sur
des mesures concrètes pour nos
chercheurs nos agriculteurs et nos
industriels
un effort important sera fait pour la
modernisation des outils d'abattage des
coupes en portant les subventions de
l'état en 2015 de 20 à 50 millions
l'urgence c'est aussi la simplification
des normes nos agriculteurs doivent être
soumis aux mêmes règles que nous voisins
européens une nouvelle méthode sera
défini pour février 2016
on est les trois font des en particulier
sur des tests et sur l'expérimentation
le but est d'associer très en amont les
professionnels agricoles à la définition
des mesures qui les concernent il ne
peut plus y avoir de sueur transposition
d'ici février
nous sommes en février aucune mesure
nationale allant au delà des obligations
européennes ne sera prise enfin
l'urgence c'est d'assurer qu'il ya une
convergence à l'échelle de l'union
européenne au conseil européen des
ministres de l'agriculture du 7 décembre
dernier à l'initiative du président de
la république nous défendrons le
relèvement du prix d'intervention du
lait les actions en faveur de
l'exportation
l'assouplissement de l'embargo russe
notamment sur le port et sur les accords
de libre échange
l'europe doit défendre ses intérêts
agricoles promouvoir ses débouchés et
éviter toute déstabilisation de chez
marché c'était le 3 septembre dernier
donc il ya tout juste cinq mois depuis
donc manuel valls on n'entend plus est -
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de savoir si
tout ça vous l'avez ressenti comme une
réalité sur le terrain
la parole et m